this video sponsored by Kings raid Kings
raid is a free-to-play side-scrolling
RPG mobile game where you can recruit
epic characters to create your own raid
gang to take out large-scale world
bosses and Dragons for bunches of
awesome loot right now they're
celebrating their 1000 day anniversary
so a special festival dungeon will be
available until November the 19th you'll
also get rewards for 7 days just for
logging in so what are you waiting for
check the link in the description and
download the game for free you wanted
more so here we are the last time we
looked at some of the most intense and
clutch anime saves we couldn't get it
down to just 10 moments that's why we're
looking at another 10 so strap on your
seat belts sit back and enjoy the ride
let's take a trip down memory lane and
relive more of the closest anime saves
we kick off with meliodas saving
Elizabeth in the seven deadly sins after
a failed attempt at killing the demon
warrior with ARC Elizabeth's moments
away from death until meliodas pops out
of nowhere dropping the demon with a
punch to the gut now we know main
characters of Shonen anime rarely stay
dead so in a series like the seven
deadly sins where everyone is Opie I had
my reservations about death sticking
especially a character let me Leodis now
that doesn't make a save any less epic
though the touching reunion and
affirmation of Elizabeth's faith in Mele
Oda's is the icing on the cake
cooties Mina
[Music]
ninth on the list is Mikasa saving
krysta now Mikasa is no stranger to
saving someone what else would you
expect from one of the most badass women
in attack on Titan rushing to the
endangered yamir krysta comes face to
face with the Titan but before she's
eaten any comes Mikasa effortlessly
killing the Titan she comes in with
reinforcements led by hanji with the
humans laying waste to the army of
Titans all of them falling victim to the
good old neck slash
[Music]
Shinra saving Tamaki comes in eighth on
the list in one of the signature moments
of the fire force Tamaki's on the
receiving end of a beat-down from
wrecker who turns out to be a bad guy
revealing his plan to create artificial
infernals he kicks and stomps the
helpless girl for her lack of loyalty
then in comes Shinra having sensed
Tamaki's distress signal Shinra descends
from the sky like a demon and stops
Rekha in the face burying the
lieutenant's face deep into the floor in
an explosive entrance not many people
find Tamaki to be an appealing character
in the cast of fire force but I
personally like her I'm pretty sure that
a lot of you changed her opinion with
this episode especially when seeing her
cry like that at the end after getting
betrayed by the person she looked up to
I'd say this is also the part where her
relationship with shinra's starts moving
forward who knows if it's the start of a
new development in the future
[Music]
seventh place on the list goes to Laxus
saving fairytale this is truly a
momentous arc in the making before the
tenro island arc the last word scene of
Laxus is his departure from the guild at
the end of his own arc after seeing the
error of his ways by Natsu in an intense
battle Laxus left fairy tail in order to
do some soul-searching of his own now
with the rest of his guild in trouble
against Hades and Makarov out of
commission
Laxus makes his move interrupting the
battle against Hades just before Hades
can strike the finishing blow and Natsu
Laxus enters with a bolt of lightning
the stuns Hades now who doesn't have a
good old redemption story the prodigal
son returns and comes back with a bang
this arced one of the last before the
now mimetic power creep in the karma
power thing really started plaguing the
series and laxus is much awaited return
serves as one of the key highlights
adoro son do some saw cuts
sixth is a memorable moment in Bleach
featuring Kenpachi and byakuya with his
oath to protect in his knack of arriving
in the nick of time you'd expect
Ichigo to appear in another of these
lists again however the tables have
turned this time as he's the recipient
of a last-second save for once even with
his newfound power
Ichigo gets pushed to the corner in a
battle against the freshly revealed
Espada number zero it would appear that
even his new powers couldn't handle the
sheer anger that fuels Yami's
transformation thankfully though two
captain's with whom he had fights with
earlier Kenpachi and byakuya arrived
returning the favor of him saving them
in the soul Society arc it should go
heads on his way to Aizen leaving Yami
with the bickering captains
[Music]
at number 5 is the badass yummy saving
the black balls from vetto
the battle against Beto is a test of
character for the black balls with the
army sideline from the battle thanks to
spatial magic the black balls are left
to fend for their own in a long and
grueling battle the squad comes out
victorious and asked to delivers what
seems to be the finishing blow to the
elf and surprisingly though the battle
doesn't end there after all it's quite
expected for a boss fight to end with
the enemy having one last trick up his
sleeve the good ol self-destruction
button if he's not gonna win he might as
well take down the whole seedbed temple
with him that's when the army finally
breaks through and slices through Vito's
magic he might have only come to strike
the finishing blow on the Fallen enemy
but who knows what might have happened
if the army hadn't come through at this
vital moment
you chill doing a cinema dinner have a
zetsubou kun ma soft on up there Oh EEMA
Jean Cocteau number four Moomin riders
saved by Saitama in one punch man now
you got a feel for movement rider
he's as low ranked as heroes come a far
cry from the titular one punch man
Saitama nevertheless he had his moment
of glory in the battle against deep sea
king
despite being outclassed by the villain
who's shown everyone a glimpse of his
power the underdog hero for Tom now
encouraged by the onlookers Moomin rider
launches an ultimately ineffective
attack on the deep-sea King and as
expected gets defeated
that's when Saitama comes in with an
epic save and in true opium fashion
finishes off the villain with his
signature one punch
a huge star so they want to they may
work
a runner-up on this list is monkey dee
dragon saving Luffy appearing again
after cementing a place among the most
badass turds in anime monkey dee dragon
saved his son in an amazing scene in Lok
Town finding himself in deep trouble
against smoker Luffy gets saved by a
massive gust of wind that blows away the
marines the source of the gust and the
savior of our protagonist none other
than his father the notorious monkey dee
dragon now the reunion between father
and son was short and not as dramatic as
you'd think it is but nevertheless it
was a very cool moment seeing the straw
hats off dragon then encourages his son
to make his dreams come true dragon
saving Luffy may have been an epic
moment but this isn't the only
last-minute save involving father and
son after all at the top we have
also kept oka yeah filter for our number
one saving the list its Minato saving
the shinobi alliance the prolonged
battle against the ten tails takes
another turn for the worse as far as our
heroes are concerned
Obito looks on triumphantly as the ten
tails proceeded to unleash your Bijoux
bomb that would surely end the good guys
with its unparalleled power as you'd
expect the attack breaks through
multiple barriers and all the techniques
that the Alliance can muster just as
bees about to be overwhelmed the Bijoux
bomb just disappears what's happened
that can only be the work of one person
nope it's not a beat Oh having a change
of heart nor is it Kakashi's
intervention the act of saving the
Alliance from the powerful attack is the
handiwork of none other than Minato who
else has a knack for teleporting tailed
beasts attacks to other dimensions than
the former Hokage talk about a collage
save with Minato in tow the battle
against the ten tails just got a little
bit more intense with that we wrap up
the list that showcases ten more
instances of last-minute saves nothing
beats the adrenaline rush following such
saves right with epic music and great
voice acting these scenes have the
potential to be remembered through the
ages as usual if you're happy with the
content feel free to like and subscribe
for more similar stuff and don't forget
to hit the bell button that way you'll
be first in line for news and updates as
Vinnie tube is planning something big in
the next few months trust me you don't
want to miss it don't forget to check
out our sponsors Gabe Kings raid the
links in the description I'll see you
next time on beanie tube
[Music]